you're now live chair
thank you um well uh welcome
to uh members of the public who have
joined us now on youtube
we're going to start the meeting now and
start with apologies
yeah first can we take a register of
attendance please yes
oh i see we're going to do it that way
round okay i was gonna do it the other
way around but never mind
now we'll do a register fair enough
okay thank you chair councillor
belton i'm here
councillor brenton president
mr bright yeah
that's the brown present
that's the bush bee brother
councillor craigie
okay thank you councillor dart
president councillor hackett
president councillor haynes president
councillor harding
councillor hawkins yeah
councillor heppel present
councillor hicks president
councillor hudson present councillor
hurley
president councillor hutchings
sorry
no he's not here no counselor thank you
councillor langford
present council of laws
president councillor leather
here councillor locke president
councillor mcgoff president
councillor mckenzie
president councillor manly
president councillor newton
president councillor pennington
president
councillor rossie
no he's not here kirsty thank you
councillor watson
councillor wiseman still here
yes thank you kirsty just to let you
know council of dart has now arrived
lovely thank you very much
right so we got some apologies in
apologies i haven't received any
all right thank you so item tune in
public contributions
and we've got some statements to be read
out
starting with kevin stevens i correct
him
steve uh yes chair um
we've got eight uh public contributions
in total so yeah if you're happy to take
that many i'll i'll go through and read
them all out all right well they won't
take that long will they know
okay carry on okay so the first one's
from kevin stevens
uh and it reads i understand that on
monday
there will be a motion going to torridge
district council
asking them to do repair works in the
museum and pioneer market
including painting the front of the
building repairing the windows
fixing the leaking roof fitting energy
efficient light in
and repairing the gate i hope that
councillors will support this motion as
i believe
these are important and highly visible
community assets
that set an immediate impression upon
visitors to the town
both locals and those from elsewhere
we run a holiday business just outside
torrington
and are often embarrassed and
disappointed when guests
comment on how shabby and tired the tone
is
we are proud to live in the area and
believe the town has the potential to
draw in more visitors and thrive
like other market towns eg south moulton
and heatherly
which are pleasant on the eye and have
thriving shopping areas
great torrenting by comparison appears
down at
down at the hill but this doesn't
reflect the reality
which is that local people are keen to
use it but are discouraged by its
poor appearance and the fact that shops
appear
incapable of synchronizing their opening
hours
it is difficult to complete a shopping
task in one visit
as the shops all open at different times
if these two issues could be addressed i
believe it would benefit everybody
during the camp pandemic it is obviously
difficult to address the opening hours
but there's an opportunity to tidy up
the town
ready to bounce back when things were
not returned to some kind of normality
you're sincerely kevin stephens
the second from linda copp
i am sorry to hear that this building
has fallen into disrepair
the town is dying with shops and
possibly other tourist attractions
being adversely affected we'll have
nothing left for people to come here for
the bar the market pannier leads
directly onto castle hill
and i hear so many tourists say i did
not even realize
this was here so it needs to be kept in
good order
along with other building attached to it
eg the museum
the third uh david gibbons
reads dear counselors i should to begin
with
introduce myself i am the new chair of
torrington museum
i've been taken over as part of a new
team of trustees in september
this year a former former torrent and
town councillor i have
been employed by the national trust for
15 years and work daily on the care of
its
historic artifacts and buildings
torrington museum currently occupies two
spaces
14 south street owned on our behalf by
great torrington town council
and the adjoining market house the upper
floor of the pannier market
and owned by tdc since we took up
occupancy of the market house torridge
district council has been supportive and
low in
access points to be built and most
recently making rent adjustments to our
landlords
great torrington town council as a
consequence of our enforced closure due
to the covid19 situation
we are appreciative of tdc's ongoing
support and enjoy
working with you i've already met with
john follows
and we have a positive and constructive
working relationship
as i understand it tdc's long-term
intention is that
great tonight and town council will also
take on a lease for the market house
so that both buildings are managed
together there are
however a number of obstacles which need
to be overcome before this can happen
as at present the building is not in
good order and is not fit to be opened
to the public
counselor bright has put in a motion
before you and i should like
to take this opportunity to support it
by restating
the existing issues which need
addressing before any handover can take
place
there's a history of structural and
mechanical failure with the lift
the bottom of the shaft is prone to
flooding and the mechanical lifting
mechanism does not work
rendering it inoperable because the
majority of showroom cinemasia on the
first floor
the market house being by far the
biggest its inaccessibility to visit
visitors with impaired mobility is a
major problem and indeed a serious
stumbling block to our ability to reopen
in 2021
all that is available to such visitors
otherwise is a reception a stairwell and
one small
cramped showroom there are also a number
of
water ingress issues which as well as
being unsightly
are detrimental to the fabric of the
building
they also present an ongoing risk to our
care of collections through the
environmental damage that coal
could pose problems as we in the process
of applying for accredited
museum status if we cannot keep our
collections in a stable
secure environment we will never achieve
that accreditation
there is a serious leak on the back of
the building above the lift shaft and
two small
smaller leaks in the ceiling which have
been observed reported
and noted for some years now the
lighting in the market house
compromises a number of elderly and
inefficient fluorescent
tube fittings which are in it which are
expensive to run
can only be changed with the tower
scaffold and should be replaced with
modern
led versions which have virtually no
running costs and a lifespan of
potentially decades
without needing to be replaced the
outside of the building is in nepal
state and reflects badly upon both the
town
and the area it is in dire need of
repainting
underlying stone and woodworking is
exposed to the elements
some windows and roof elements are in a
fragile condition
which as i am sure you realize is a
major problem for grade two listed
building
action taken now will prevent further
deterioration
and even more expensive remedial work in
years to come when budgets are likely to
be stretched even more thinly than at
present
i understand this is a short but
complicated list
and i am and i am aware that there are
other issues with the penny market
but i urge councillors to support
councillor bright's motion to protect
and preserve
a unique and invaluable part of our town
and region's heritage for future
generations
uh the next one is sue shrub so hello as
i
as you know i rent one pannier market
from yourselves
and i believe i am a good tenant to you
i now find my shop
being targeted as the shabbiest part of
central torrenton
let in standards slip i have already
stated that if a rent increase
ensures all opinion market tenants i
would like some of the revenue to be
invested in refurbishing the building
it appears the rest of the town agrees
please can you advise
advise me that something will be done
regarding the building
and soon susan schrozzon
the next one's from reverend dr susanna
metz
to whom it may concern i am writing to
express my extreme displeasure
at our government's decision to vote
against protecting food standards in the
agriculture bill
it is especially distressing after being
promised by our own
mp and many others protecting not only
our food standards
but also the standards in place for the
welfare of our animals
would not be compromised in any trade
deals
i also feel that going forward on a no
deal brexit is irresponsible and it is
having
an impact on how our farming industry is
being sold out
i continue here with a focus on the us
as that is where i have most experience
working with
and for farmers other than here in north
devon
i am a permanent resident in this
country having come from the united
states
whilst my primary position in both
countries has been
as a member of the clergy i have also
been involved in working
on owner-operated farms as well as being
involved in sustainable agriculture
advocacy
groups such as rural church network
a us rural advocacy group rural
chaplains association international
appalachian education resource center
us farmers for action uk
etc i have seen firsthand
how agribusiness in the us has
undermined not only food standards
but also wealth for animal welfare
in the us i have worked with immigrants
involved in multinational chicken
corporations
who have been treated abysmally by those
corporate giants
yes the us is geographically huge but
all across the nation
land is being dismaled at an alarming
rate by an angry
business political machine that allows
such things
things as manure lakes animals housed by
thousands on land that cannot sustain
them
the use of pesticides bovine growth
hormones and antibiotics
antibiotics in an unsafe and poorly
regulated manner
and an immoral lack of care for the
people who for generations have seen
their life work as providing healthy
food for the world's people
i have seen the despair in the eyes of
those farmers
and as we have seen in our own country
here the devastation of a family
who loses someone to suicide is this the
kind of partnership
in a trade deal we want for this country
do we want to see foods from countries
that can undersell us because of their
quite
frankly unethical and immoral
agricultural
practices coming onto our store shelves
i hope to god not true but to honest
to be honest i wonder when i read uh how
our own government is responding to the
desperate attempts of our farmers
to have their voices heard i have
marched with the ffa
to number 10 down the street and have
watched as farmers i know
drove their tractors to london in
peaceful demonstrations begging our
government to help us
the response has been negligible almost
as insulting as a pat on the head
live in one of the most glorious
agricultural areas in our country
the beauty of our small family owned and
operated
farms who produce food for local
consumption as well as
production that feeds our country
further afield
assures us that our food is nutritious
and then we can believe
what we read on the products labels
in the us there's constant controversy
over what needs to be labeled and quite
honestly
many in the us have little confidence in
the government's willingness to be
completely honest especially
when sunny purdue was chosen by the
current
current president to head the department
of agriculture
i could rest my case right there if we
ignore
the need to support and encourage
sustainable farming in our country
we leave ourselves open to finding our
supermarket shelves filled with food
that is far
inferior health-wise to that we can grow
here
yes it will be cheap but we will only
have to read the problems people in the
us
are having for example because because
of the insane use of corn syrup sugar in
foods
that actually have no need of it
we will be tempted to buy dairy products
that could easily have antibiotic and
bst
in them is this what we want
in the dalton georgia area us southeast
hospitals were finding a much greater
percentage of women who presented with
breast masses
were treated uh which were traced back
to cheap milk
these women were however mexican
immigrants
brought into the us to work in the
carpet and chicken
factories so they don't make the
headlines they are expendable
is that what we want to share
i will admit to being an idealist
perhaps because i'm clergy
i'm hardwired to look first at what is
moral what is ethical
what is good for all people instead of
looking first at
the econom economics are we more
interested in getting something for
nothing
regardless of the effect it has on those
at the bottom of the food chain
those who are actually doing the work
and giving their lives providing
nutritious
food whose pockets are we willing to
fill
regardless of how questionable food
sources affect the health of our people
how much faith are we willing to put in
the hands of corporate leaders
who in one instance fall asleep when we
when he was supposedly on a fact-finding
flyover
of agricultural land ideally love to see
every member who voted against
protecting our food standards spend a
week
working on a farm listening to groups of
farmers on their land
and in their homes not being hosted in
town halls for an hour so they can
trot out their canned speeches
yes i'm angry yes i'm frustrated and yes
i
fear for the future of our farmers who
are willing and able to try new things
to keep the production of our british
food
at the highest standards possible
i fear for the future of our young
people who desperately
it's gone on a very long time this one
so uh is it nearly finished
um i've got a couple of sentence to go
to last couple of sentences to go
right for the family breaks my heart and
i hear a local farmer tell me over and
over that he understands my passion for
all
this but what can we do it's coming and
there's nothing we can do about it we
may as well go with it
i tell him i will continue to speak out
i will continue to encourage my farm
families
from the pulpit and from our from the
milk in parma where i work not to lose
hope and
to be willing to organize and fight for
the right to make our voices heard and
listen to
we must demand that our government
listens to us and makes decisions
uh that support ethical and moral
practices in the food industry and
support our british farmers
people with whom i've lived and worked
in the us constantly tell me how envious
they are of our food system over here
they say you don't want what we have
here i can only hope that our voices
will be heard
and this government will review and
reverse their vote against upholding the
standards of our food production
right uh chair the next ones keely allen
to whom it may concerned please find the
below comment a support for the motion
that counselor bright is putting forward
regarding the penny market in great
torrents
i would like to write in support of the
motion being put forward by councillor
bright
our pioneer market is one of the jewels
in our crown and attracts a lot of
visitors and also is the main walkway
from bali grove car park
i therefore think it is of great
importance that it is maintained
made to look its very best i'm aware of
works that have gone on regarding
drainage and grateful of the work that
has been done so far in this area as
well as the huge improvements to the
staff toilets
in addition it's lovely to see see it
now
being regularly cleaned to a high
standard it really does make a huge
difference
it would be great now to see the works
completed the front edge of the pannier
market is looking in a very sorry state
and along with the broken gates
and rotten windows it does not give the
right impression of what fantastic shops
we have just inside
we need to show off the units and make
it look inviting to
locals and visitors alike having heard a
while ago that energy efficient
lights will also be installed it would
be beneficial to see this completed too
it is becoming ever more important that
we preserve the environment and i think
any steps we can take to ensure this
happens
will only be good for the town i hope
all councillors will give
good consideration to this motion and
support council bright
and great torrington in improving the
look of this huge asset
to our town
chair the next ones from sue leach uh
dear sirs and madames we are very lucky
to have such history in small town and
torrington
if the pannium if the penny market could
only talk
it is our duty to keep premises like
these in good condition
for future generations to enjoy i
therefore hope that some of the town
council funds
could be put to good use in this
direction the square in torrington is so
very important and not something the
town can afford to lose
okay the final ones from sebastian mason
torridge councillors and others
concerned with the agriculture bill
to say i'm concerned would be an
understatement for a second time
my mp jeffrey cox has voted against
amendments to the agriculture bill
that will protect the food standards in
this country as well as
all the workers and families that depend
on farming for their income and life
i have been brought up on what is now a
free-range chicken and beef farm
i have spent my years shadowing my other
family members learning to do things
right to protect the consumers with food
safety standards
and to give the livest stock on our farm
the welfare and quality of life they
deserve
overall the purpose of the work we put
in is to produce a much better product
for the uk consumers
as many other farming families would
agree there is a huge amount of passion
and pride that goes into what we do
and sadly now that passion is dwindling
as of writing this on the farm we are
currently halfway through a chicken
turnaround
to put it simply this is the time when
the last lot of chickens go for
processing and the new lot of chicks
come in to start the new crop
however this is not as simple as it
sounds this the week
during turnaround is filled by two main
concepts
by a security and cleaning once the muck
has been removed the sheds are cleaned
throughout
with pressure washers no area can be
left untouched as this could cause
infection in the next crop
and therefore put the consumers of the
chicken at risk
the sheds are then disinfected and the
outside areas washed we all must have
separate clothing and boots for the
poultry areas of the farm to prevent
cross-contamination
then once the chicks are placed this
biosecurity continues throughout the
rest of the crop
this doesn't stop there are no breaks
from biosecurity
it must be maintained which isn't
happening with some of the food that
could be imported to the uk
our chickens are free range meaning they
have a higher welfare standard than
other birds available
this means once four weeks old we let
them out every morning and shut them in
again at night these processes become
part of the routine
and with the right weather conditions
and when the birds are brave enough can
take up many hours of your week
that could be put to other jobs but we
do this so the birds have a higher
standard living
the sheds are also lessly less densely
packed
with lots of objects hanging from the
ceiling and perches
purchases perches placed around the shed
for the chickens
to and birds to interact with as a form
of enrichment
a lot of time goes into raising the
standard of living for the chickens we
keep
much of the same goes for the beef side
of our farm we only have a small herd
mainly brought in to manage our
conservation ground
but moving forward we know we need a
niche this means we need to have some
sort of welfare standard put on
on the beef we sell so we can prove that
we are giving them the best quality of
life possible
however with this amendment being
rejected by many mps including jeffrey
we cannot help but struggle to see how
work into a higher standard
will benefit us moving forward i am very
concerned as to how much drive
i and other future generations in the
industry will have to achieve the high
standards
we feel are needed on our farms to
produce the best quality product for the
uk consumers
how will consumers know what they are
buying is not at the british safety
standards
already it's hard for us to show
consumers what goes
into their food so i hate to imagine
what this will be like in years to come
will we see a rise in infections due to
poor food production practices
the fears of us being undercut with
lower quality foods
and having consumers not know what they
are buying are real and are growing
i wrote to my mp last time there was an
amendment but it's
but it's obvious my message was not
clear enough to him
when an mp operates in rural area
and isn't concerned with how their votes
can impact local industries
are they really the representative of
the of the people
they meant to they made out to be i have
to wonder
how this vote will affect the
conservative voters in our area
with so many of them being from a
farming background
hopefully something can be done thank
you for taking the time to read my views
chair that's all the public
contributions
thank you very much steve well done that
was a that was a bit of a marathon but
never mind
it's so people expressing their views so
next item three declarations of interest
or members you know
the score on that one you have to
declare that as and when
that item arises on the agenda so then
we go to
agreements between part of one
and two and we need to take a vote on
that under our present constitution
so uh we need to go through that as you
can see there's one item for
for part two which is to do with our
major contracts
commercially sensitive uh
so who's gonna who's gonna take the vote
who's gonna record votes
i'll do that chad thank you kirsty
churchill
[Music]
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
oh councillor craigie or
councillor dart four councillor ford
four councillor cub
or councillor hackett for
councillor homes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor harley
councillor hurley no i think we've lost
him kirsty
okay thanks councillor hutchings
councillor inch for counselor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
councillor laws paul
councillor leather or councillor lock
or councillor mcgoff or
councillor mackenzie for
councillor manley paul councillor newton
councillor pennington or councillor
watson councilor wiseman
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much
kirsty so now we go to item
six urgent matters of one item to bring
to your
attention um councillors namely the uh
disappointment that the devon county are
not
supporting the uh free school meal
program that many other local
authorities are including somerset next
door
during this half term period and
clearly we'll see what happens over the
christmas one but i would uh
suggest that we should contact
devon county to find out how we can
assist because bear in mind we have lost
our community grants money that we used
to
and many of us counselors did actually
put that into the food banks
so that uh our bearing and bearing in
mind that we have
one of the poorest districts in the
country um
it is not good enough i don't think that
uh our young people
are left exposed in this way so
as i say that that is my intention to do
that
is to write to the county and ask what
they intend to do
certainly about christmas which is
coming up now
uh steve if you've got anything that um
you want to uh
raise um
as i said this this morning i emailed uh
felony chief executive of
uh dublin county to ask the question uh
that you just posed i have circulated
uh a statement which devon county
council
put on their their website today so i
circulated that to all councillors
um so what that indicates is that
the county council has made resources
available not specifically
targeted at free school meals but made
resources available
for hardship so any individuals
experience
in hardship can apply to district
councils storage included
for help and support and that could uh
go towards
providing meals for those families but
it's um
as you said it's not a specific
decision for free school meals
i think the other thing to point out to
counselors is that on devon live there
is a whole list
of um
people or companies and and um
cafes pubs etc that are prepared to
help and provide meals for
children during this half term so if you
look on that
devon live list you'll see that there
are several local ones i just bring to
minded redline for example at clavelli
uh but there are many many others so um
they're doing their bit
in the commercial world i'm pleased to
say so hopefully
um it won't be as dire as
it could be so we go to um
chair councillor hutchins has raised his
hand
can i just make another comment as well
sorry
very important okay i was just i was
just gonna say could i just add another
comment
sure yeah it is only to say
um torridge's own hardship fund we will
be
um issuing a our own internal press
release
to remind residents that we have money
available uh for those experiencing
hardship as well so we'll be issuing
a reissue in that press release um and
i'll be asking harry and the team to do
that tomorrow
right okay
so is counselor making a point of order
or something i don't know
i mean there is there is no debate on
it's not uh it's not an item which is on
the agenda as such
per say through the challenge wondering
if i could make a comment
on what you've just made a comment on
regarding uh school meals
uh no you can't we're gonna move on to
the next item which is
uh for planning for the white paper okay
well there will be a report coming back
cancer hutchins so you can you can be
able to comment make your comments then
okay
um so item six then
planning future white paper as you know
you've got a
supplement this is uh quite a lengthy
document as you can see and uh we need
to
uh although something's popped up on the
front what's happening here
can you hear me all right
yeah we can hear your chamber not see
you all right well that that's an
advantage for everybody
but never mind you need to answer an
update
all right i've done that
i don't think he cancelled it i think he
pressed update
just received an update on the ipad
sorry
i am actually press cancel on my own
screen and it went away
we've all got it at the same time that's
an improvement counselor brenton
perhaps you're next mr golf
as the chair is currently in an update
would it be appropriate to have the
voice chair take over
yeah catholic christian should take
last minute or two it happened last week
to me it only lasts a minute
i'll take it over if you like
yes not coming back or we'll need a vote
on that
members if we if you'll be back by the
time we've taken the vote
right uh if i can ask uh stacy to take
the vote
or whoever is doing it kirsty kesley can
you take the vote please
yes of course do we need a proposal in a
second yes please yes we do
i'll second it
i think is councillor newton proposing
yeah i'll propose if it gets us underway
all second
thank you councillor bowton
now he's one we've lost i believe
or councillor cottle honkin
councillor craigie for councillor dart
[Music]
four councillor ford four
harding for councillor hawkins
or councillor heppel or
councillor hicks or councillor hodson
for councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings
because i went offline
yeah okay so i don't know what we're
voting on here
it's a vote of no confidence on your own
for yeah okay
thank you that's unanimous then chair
whatever it was i don't know why this
wretched machine decided to uh update
itself right in the middle and cut off
so however i'm back back again you'll be
delighted to know
no you're not i'm not you can't hear me
yeah we can hear you all right okay
so where are we steve tell me where we
are okay we're in this we're in the same
place we were just voting to nominate a
new chair
but no no you're back so we're still on
item six
all right i should have stayed off a bit
longer then shouldn't i
right okay on a point of order please
yes what what point of order the point
of order is
if the chair is in dispose surely the
deputy chair can take over
without needing to go to a vote a
lengthy vote
yeah you're quite right i think yeah i
mean
it's a bit ludicrous we were part way
through having a lengthy vote when you
came back on
yeah no no i think that's quite right i
think the invitation to take over
straight away
it's only if he's a disposer or she is
in disposal
have to decide on choosing a chair
another one rather
yeah quite right okay well you proceed
anyhow so
we've got an officer leading us on this
one i hope
ian yes yes we do chair
thank you good evening thank you chair i
was just going to introduce you and say
that
you know there are 25 points on here and
i do hope members have read it
yeah definitely in indeed uh i hope
members have read it
my name is ian roland and i'm a senior
planning policy officer here at torres
district council good evening to
members officers members of the public
now the purpose of the item
is to consider the council's formal
response to the government's
consultation on the planning reforms as
set out
in the white paper planning for the
future
for information and in case members wish
to submit their own personal responses
the consultation closes at 11 45 on the
29th of october
you have a proposed draft response
that's been circulated to you
after the agenda came out at appendix
one of the reports
now this has been prepared
collaboratively by officers here at
torres district council
and at north devon council bringing
together our professional expertise
in particular elizabeth d planning
policy officer from north devon council
along with sean harrington development
manager and dawn burgess a colleague of
mine in planning policy
from torridge have been involved
although we've drawn upon expertise of
others along the way
i think it's important to say that it's
been prepared to reflect the views of
members
here at torridge we've sought to
articulate the views and the sentiments
that have been reflected to us over the
past few weeks at the series of events
that we've held
and through the opportunities we've
given them to be involved and pass their
comments to us
along with those comments are received
directly from members through emails
or on the online form whilst
officers from north devon and torrid
have been working collaboratively
the responses proposed for both
authorities share some common core
what we have done is made sure that
we've reflected
the individual views and the particular
views of each district's members where
appropriate so they have a common core
but we have got different aspects to
reflect the different views of torridge
and north devon
so the north devon response will look
different to the turret's response
we do need to highlight to members that
the version of the response that's
presented to them in appendix 1
does have an error at question 12 and
more astute with you will have
noticed that question 12 the final
sentence is truncated
and it's missing its second half this
paragraph is raising concerns about the
timetable
and the capacity of the planning
inspectorate to meet their 30-month
timetable
so it is intended to read should this
occur
the council is concerned about the
capacity of the planning inspectorate
to facilitate examinations in a timely
manner
and would seek assurance that any
associated delays
would not result in penalties for the
local planning authority
so that is the full sentence that is
meant to be at the end of the response
for
question 12. and we would seek to append
those missing
words when submitted i'd like to take
the opportunity to apologize to members
that it does also contain a number of
spelling mistakes and grammatical errors
and highlights that that is reflective
of the fact the time frames for the
completion
and circulation to members were
exceedingly tight to make sure we took
your views into accounts
and had those workshops etc we'll assure
members again
that we seek to correct these mistakes
and errors prior to the submission to
government
right accordingly sorry chair
okay nearly done right accordingly
we we do suggest a minor amendment to
the recommendation
recommendation one on page six of your
agenda
to read one endorse the draft response
to the government consultation
on the proposed planning reforms
appendix 1
subject to the completion of the final
paragraph in response to question 12 as
stated
and the correction of any spelling
grammatical or other errors of a minor
nature
so at this stage i'd ask members to
consider the response at appendix one
and the recommendations are page six of
their reports subject to that suggested
amendment
and i'll hand back to the chair and note
that we would be happy
to answer any questions i have sean
harrington
uh dawn burgess and elizabeth d
alongside me this evening to be able to
help
answer those questions thank you chair
thank you thank you ian right so
councillors
if we start at the beginning then um
what i propose to do is to go through
the numbers and you see the officer's
response
on our behalf if you
don't agree with it or you propose an
amendment or
addendum or whatever then you make your
view known and we will vote on that and
if
and then we'll take a substantive vote
at the end if that if it's approved or
rejected as the case may be we then take
a substantive vote at the very end of
the report
are you happy with that any decision
sorry uh you've got three hands raised
already counsellor
the council of loch and councillor haims
okay we'll take them in order then
council or leather first thanks chad no
i'm not happy that we're going to go
through
this document uh question by question
like that there's an awful lot of work
gone into this
and i'm i've read through this planning
document
the white paper um i've been
as other members have also been to
various meetings online
to do with this white paper
members have had plenty of opportunities
to put their responses in
i personally have sent a personal
response i've been online
and filled in this questionnaire which
is a difficult thing to do i gave up
once it was
it's so obscure in places so little
information on some of it
but i did phone up this afternoon and
spoke with dom
burgess and wanted to pass pass on my
personal thanks to daunted ian
to sean and to those at north devon
council who've done it
for me an exceptional piece of work
on this dra on this draft here that
we've got before us
and if we're going to go through it one
by one
i just can't see the point of it members
have had plenty of chance to have read
through this
and either they accept the document as
it is
or it has to go back i mean the 29th is
the
when we're up and i was just going to
move that we accept the recommendations
on both with with the
with the added bit that ian just
mentioned then about the sentence and
the grammatical
et cetera i want to move those those
recommendations share
well if you're proposing that and that's
just been seconded by cancer watson is
that right
that's right chair okay well you know
that's a proposition that's
the second i'm quite happy to take a
vote on that but
other members won't want to put their
say something prior to that
who's the next one councillor locks next
chair
that's a lot okay i agree that we should
go straight into the boat but i just
um had two points to mention i was glad
um that on pages 28 and 29
we've got a long and detailed response
for affordable house and i think that's
most important
but i was puzzled by the bottom of page
12
the response is mixed now there's the
only time that you've used that to mix
around all the questions because
normally it's yes
no i'm not sure so i wonder what the
difference was between mixed and not
sure
uh ian could you answer that please
yes certainly chet um if you look to the
question uh
it's do you agree with the proposals for
the consent regimes for renewal and
protected areas
the reason that we suggest mixed is
because we agree with one but not
the other yeah is that the same as not
sure then
i i think it's slightly different to not
sure in that we part agree and
part disagree yeah
piece of work and i go along with the
two previous speakers
thank you and the spelling's different
okay so um all right so um
tom is there anybody else who's uh yeah
it's uh councillor haynes is next chair
thanks chair um yeah i'd like to
congratulate the officers on excellent
piece of work um you know it's really
hard job to do and
i think in general they've done it well
it's just
i wonder whether it gets off to a quite
a good start onto question one i'm a bit
sort of perplexed when they're asked
what three words describe associate with
a planning system
and um you say they say
complicated contentious and essential um
that sounds a bit sort of negative to me
i
don't know whether it's supposed to i
mean i was going to refer you to dalk's
responses
to the uh white paper when they they use
the words
local flexible and the thorough and i
thought they were better words
personally
i just maybe um ian roland can answer
that through you
chair ian
responds to that ian yeah thank you
thank you chair um
these were three words that were uh the
most popular words that were brought up
by our local planned working group
when we presented the questions to them
and certainly
we've mentioned them in sort of
subsequent workshops
and they're the three that certainly we
felt reflected
members views from that uh early
engagement
um now i i think they are reflective
of the planning and it's the planning
system as it stands at the moment
uh so obviously members have
have different views and i'm sure every
member you ask in in
in this meeting would probably have
different views about which which words
to pick
they're the three that were the the top
pick from from the working group and
they're the ones we
we present before you this evening chair
so i just even come back i mean it
rather
indicates that the white paper is
necessary and the the basic premise of
the white paper that the planning system
now is
needs drastic overall it rather seems to
indicate to me that
that um our council agrees
using those words but that's my my
observation
i would i would propose that we use the
words in doubt but
i don't ever get a second
is there a secondary for the what
councilor haines just proposed
we substitute the words locals flexible
and thorough for the
words which were in this report
because it currently isn't chair it's
low it's local it's flexible it's
thorough compared what the government's
proposing anyway
that's the point and then we don't have
a second order for that i'm afraid
counseling
thank you chair councillor hodson's next
hi thank you very much like everyone
else well done
um a huge task you've undertaken
however just a couple of little points
um given the devolution proposals that
we are also
facing um i think we need to be a little
bit cautious in a couple of the
responses
on page 15 we refer to ourselves
as a small rural authority
which has concerns over access to
technology
i think we just need to actually delete
the word
small because we don't want it to be
blamed that
um we are small and this is why we are
struggling
the key component part about it is
that we are sorry rural
and we have problems with access
to digital services so i would suggest
that we just delete the word small
and delete unlike some larger
authorities because that doesn't
uh make any um it doesn't add to it
um and just make the council does not
have access to dedicated teams of
specialists
and then again it says support the
information
implementation of the proposals for
and we say small again i think delete
these words small
and it still has the strength to
emphasize the issues
um the second part where in the document
where you refer to us as being
small is page 26
the second paragraph on page 26
reads um with further reference to the
lack of details how
to how the proposal would operate it's
easy to conclude the management of
collecting the levy
will add a significant administrative
burden on
it's going to add an administrative
burden to everybody so
just on local authorities and
delete such as torridge as currently and
i think this is one of the grammatical
things
you would referring to you've written
enabled a proportion of receipts
i presume that will be enacted or some
other word for that
but i do think that the issue about
calling us small
detracts from the real message about us
being a rural
authority um
page 19
uh the third paragraph down is just
about
ordering i think the message in this
paragraph is
to facilitate effective delivery of
development the council believes that
it's essential that the government apply
measures
to either incentivize delivery by
developers
and or to impose penalties for
non-implementation
it's the last sentence i think this
paragraph
personally would be much stronger if it
started with that one
um and
no the other one was as you said a
correction in your
uh it was respond and you should have
response but uh
that is immaterial but i would like to
ask er what he thinks about those
those issues and whether they merit
some minor amendments otherwise i think
the document
the document is superb thank you
well uh in um reaction to that
i suppose my reaction is the reality is
we
are a small local authority here
here that actually does help our
argument but there you go
um in please chair
i i think the the intent and the thrust
of the argument
would still be there if we were to
remove those words and
move to what council hodgson suggests um
but it is down to members to to choose
whether they wish to do so of course
right well
i'm not denying the fact that we are
small but one of the questions we are
facing
is that we are so small we should be
absorbed into a greater
uh for the greater good into a large
organization and i think we don't want
to give fuel
to the suggestion that we are small and
inadequate
so that's why i suggested the removal of
the word small i know we're small
but we're strong in our partnerships and
the way we work together with
north devon over this matter right
well i don't think we it depends if ian
is happy to have that removed because
it's his report
and uh on our behalf but um otherwise
you'll have to go to the vote and get a
second
for that yeah i'm i'm happy either way
um i think i think it's down to members
to make that decision on whether or not
they wish to
to have those wordings removed well is
there a secondary council
o'clock councillor clark force second
council
okay in that case uh i'm going to put
that to the vote then that we remove the
words small
so it's proposed and seconded and
away we go thank you chair councillor
belton
uh four councillor brenton engaged
councillor bright ball
councillor brown against
councillor bushby again councillor
christie
against
abstain i don't really mind either way
councillor craigie bohr
dart or councillor ford
four councillor gov
abstain councillor hackett
councillor haines or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins
councillor heppel abstain
chancellor hicks against
councillor hudson or
councillor hurley against
councillor hutchings
councillor hutchings
no we've lost him cursed i believe okay
thank you councillor inch
against councillor james
um i just have to abstain so i've missed
what we're proposing
thank you councillor jones
against councillor langford
for
councillor laws
councillor leather against because we
are a small rural authority
councillor locke against councilman
thank you chris against
councillor mckenzie
against councillor manly
or councillor newton
against councillor pennington
councillor watson
councillor wiseman against
thank you
okay so that's 13 4 seventeen against
and four abstentions chair
thank you very much councillors that's
uh that's lost
so um sorry stays as it is does it
it does yeah fine okay so now um
i suppose that we um accept the report
and i would like to add my um
congratulations to the officers for the
work they've done on this it was uh
very readable although long of course
but nonetheless it was uh
something you could read about getting
caught down into much
jargon et cetera just to let you know
you've still got four hands up oh thank
you i'm so sorry i push it through well
we'll put that one on on hold then until
we've heard the other four people
we've got councillor christie next sorry
how's it christy thank you well this is
a consultation and i
i i actually like what the officers put
for the most part
but i think we ought to have as
counselors we will have some input into
this consultation just to
reflect the corporate view and there's
three points i would like to
bring up and they all come from
my fairly long association with planning
uh the first one and plan and the plans
committee who have heard this before
it's about site constraints uh because
on page five this is
actually addressed but we do need
to investigate sites before we give
planning permission on them because what
happens
time and time again is the sites come
before us
we give outline planning permission and
then the developer turns around with his
whole list of problems and costs and
expenses
therefore he can't afford to do this
can't afford to do that
if we had a survey beforehand to
actually identify these sites
that would stop all that nonsense it
should be paid for
by the developer or the owner of the
land and i think we ought to have that
in this plan
or in this consultation sorry the second
point is it's on
page eight um it's about the constraints
on sites again now if you've been on
plans committee you'll know that i've
been asking for years and it's finally
happened
that we do get the district valuers
reports on these sites
because the developer will put forward
all the problems how much is going to
cost and so on
and inevitably it seems
we lose out in terms of affordable
housing in terms of infrastructure and
so on
but the one thing that is missing from
the specific values report
is the actual cost of the site what is
the developer paid for
so it makes the whole valuation
nonsensical
and i think we should ask for that in
this consultation
because otherwise we are well it's
completely pointless asking for the
value of judgment
and the third point is it's on page 10
this is about the actual delivery of
buildings now this is a big problem we
all
are aware that planning commissions have
been given
that they could be years before they
finished
you go in you dig a couple of trenches
you say you started
and years later it happens it holds up
the whole system
and i was interested to read there that
even the government is saying perhaps we
need
sanctions or uh incentives to actually
speed this up
and i think we should really stress that
uh that we support that i don't mind
which
but otherwise all we're doing is we're
piling up planning permissions
that developers are well they're just
using as financial assets
they don't seem to have any uh actual
aim to build these things
so there's three points there i would
like included or at least
stressed in this consultation that's
going back to the government
okay thank you for that ian can they be
stressed or do we need to actually
make this a actual uh point that needs
to be voted on
um jeff we we can certainly try and
incorporate the views
um in into the response um i
i think none of us disagree with some
some of the
the principles that have been raised
there um i think there's challenges
around some of those things that have
been raised
in terms of seeking info about
constraints that's certainly a point
that we've highlighted is necessary
should they go forward with these
reforms
in that it's essential that if we are
granting outlined consent
in growth areas through the
uh local plan process then it's
essential that we do have that
information
up front so that we can make those
decisions and i think we have stressed
that quite clearly
in in terms of of the response chair um
i think it's it's it's challenging to to
go any further than that and say that
that's what we should be doing now
one of our concerns certainly is about
the capacity of us as a local authority
to be able to do that
if it is imposed upon us that we need to
do that task
um and you'll have seen that it talks
about we looked at 600 sites through the
local plan process
with our with our colleagues in north
devon and allocated over 100 of those
doing that sort of work as a local
authority would be incredibly
challenging
i understand what councilor christie is
suggesting in terms of we would need
that information to be provided by
the applicants or the developers
i'm not quite sure how that would work
in practice we can certainly look at
whether or not we can strengthen the
wording there
in terms of valuations certainly i don't
know whether sean harrington wishes to
come in and
discuss that at all um
sean have you got some input on that
uh thank you chair thank you ian good
afternoon members
uh yeah in relation this is a matter
that plans committee have been grappling
with for
um some time as esconds the christie's
aware
in our response to uh question 22a
which i believe is on page 22 23 of your
document
we do make we do make note of
um the issues we have with viability and
land values particularly
in torridge i'm not sure those
paragraphs
capture what council christies wants to
emphasize or not but we can certainly
look at putting that earlier on in the
conversation document
if that is what council christie's
actually after in relation to land
values
it is an issue that we do have at torres
of course
and viability is a concern um clearly
there's no actual details in this white
paper how viability will be dealt with
um and certainly the small leading time
to
draft a local plan uh in relation to
sites which essentially be granted
outline plan permission is a very
very big concern which i think has been
articulated within
this consultation response um so of
course it's up to members to decide if
they want to strengthen that element of
this constitutional response
thank you chair thank you councillor
christine are you
content with those or do you want to
move an actual well yes
although there is one specific point i
didn't ask for the district valuer
reports actually including
the site because otherwise they're not
worth the paper they're written on
right um ian in response to that
we can certainly look at where we can
put that in in the reports in in the
response
chair um i don't know if counselor
counselor christy would like to liaise
with this
afterwards or tomorrow maybe in terms of
finding a particular spot for that
thank you very much all right okay uh
councillor bushby is next
mr bushby thank you chair
um you know clearly this is a
quite a quite a detailed document to
actually read through i just wanted to
make the point um
in reading it that there are eight
um no not sure by the officers
um so you know in reading it's
sometimes difficult to actually come up
with the definitive answer when the
officers themselves are clearly overpaid
professionals
um are putting not sure you know on
eight of the eight of the headings it's
just a
point that i wanted to make because it's
um some of the things i'm not sure
myself
and a better steer would have been a
little bit you know
um more comforting right
i think the government's not sure either
to be honest but there you go
um uh sorry here's the next one
uh councillor hurley chair answer hurley
thank you chair um yes i fully agree
with other councillors when they talk
about how well presented this report is
and in such
a short space of time so well done to
the officers involved
um following on council christie said
i'm very pleased to note
that uh talking about bridging the gap
between
when that planning application is
allowed and when the houses or whatever
are built out
it seemed to me when i first came on the
council it was ridiculous that
the council's trying to give uh talk
about
five-year land supply a lot of
developers
are sitting on land it's doing nothing
this shouldn't be and i maintained at
that
time that instead of saying you've got
so we say three years to
to build out on the application um but
by starting the application within that
time it goes on
in perpetuity therefore i fully support
any
um any rules or any changes to that
that says you have to actually build out
within the three years
um so i'm very pleased with that the one
or two other things i was happy about on
here as well but i think they've been
answered by your
questions uh other councils are but so
well done to the team for getting this
report
in such a short space of time and a very
comprehensive one thank you
okay thank you councillor pennington's
next chair
repenting thank you chair um same
comments about well done to the officers
uh my question is on page eight seven b
uh
could strategic cross-boundary issues be
best planned for in the absence of
formal
duty to cooperate um i know when we did
the uh last plan for torridge uh there
was a duty cooperate we
involved health and social care um in
the wording there is that
purely on local authority boundary
neighbors and does it
include where our thinking would be with
health education
social care etc and are we relying on to
be retrospectively addressed
examination would that possibly at all
come in or would it be lost
altogether it's a question and i don't
want to change it at the moment
because i don't think you can answer a
change but i did get concerned
on the doorstep people say we've got all
these houses where are the services
going to be to support the people that
are going to live here
and i just wanted to be a little more
understand of what the examination
process would be
at the top of page nine thank you chair
thank you ian yes chair
if if i may um i i think one of the
problems as has been highlighted earlier
in the evening is that
there's a lot of uncertainty about what
the proposals might bring about
and certainly here they were talking
about the removal of the duty to
cooperate
and not suggesting an alternate
mechanism and i think we were concerned
that without knowing what is going to
replace it
um it is very hard for us to comment
certainly i think
to answer councillor pennington's
question yes the duty to corporate does
go wider than just your neighboring
authorities
and certainly across devon we had a
protocol in place that would allow us to
engage proactively with
other organizations as well that were
signatories to that
which included included health and
social care through devon county council
etcetera so it's not only about
just your your neighbouring authorities
but those that have
the powers and overlap your authority
so i i think we we we were concerned
that we don't have the clarity of what
might replace it that actually it did
work reasonably effectively for us
in terms of north devon and torridge
with eczema national park and with those
other partners
but maybe that's because this time
around we didn't have such contentious
issues to deal with as we see in some
other places
in terms of the retrospective at
examination that's a peculiarity of
the examination process in that
if you enter if you submit your local
plan and you go into examination
you are no longer able to fulfill that
test if you failed it or it's judged
that you failed it in terms of that duty
to cooperate
so if someone successfully argues that
examination
that you haven't cooperated
appropriately and met that
specific test then it's not in the power
of the local plan examiner
to be able to currently fix that issue
and you have to
go back a stage in terms of your plan
making on
pull out of your examination withdraw
from the examination
and try and revisit that as a as an
exercise and try and cooperate with your
neighbors and come to an agreement
or otherwise and then resubmit
so i think it has been elsewhere a
problem
that's reached through examination and
it was just a suggestion as one of the
things that could be done
to allow it to be retrospectively fixed
through the examination process
as they do with many other things such
as housing numbers etc at the moment
so that that was the suggestion chair i
always think retrospective and planning
go very well together chair thank you
very much indeed
right thank you the final one chairs
councillor haims
right thank you
yeah thank you chair for allowing me to
come back um yeah coming out of what
council christie says and i agree with
what he says about assessing sites and
things
um i'm not really happy really about
page 24 under
question 22a uh second paragraph
last sentence starting the current
system generally works well
um representing appledore i can't think
that um many
people in april would agree that the
system is working well
um it goes on to talk about viability
and affordable housing
and infrastructure well these are the
things that come out time and time again
and that you know things aren't working
well really and you heard counts
you heard councillor shelly from
northern talking last meeting about this
very passionately
and i i'd feel happier really if this
sentence was taken out
um it gives maybe the wrong impression
that we're happy with the system
though we're not happy with the white
paper either but
i would propose that we admit we take
that out but whether i get second i
don't know but if we don't take it out
then perhaps
ian roland can look at it again
[Music]
i'd second that mr chairman sorry
who was that there's councilman garfield
second council haynes
on that thank you i just want you can
say it's because you should actually
tell me exactly the second what counts
just said about removing that sentence
i'm just trying to identify the sentence
if you would give us a chance
it's the second sentence and the second
sorry the third paragraph in
question 22a starting the current system
generally works well the council work
with the development industry adopting a
flexible approach etc
right okay do you propose that's
uh deleted
and that's been seconded by counseling
with golf
so we're we'll go to the vote on that
yeah how much of that before we do can
you just explain
how much of that is it being proposed to
take out
the whole sentence chair a whole
sentence
on page 20 yeah i've got it
on page 24 it is yeah yeah
well that again states the exact
position that we are in at the moment
yeah the problem is chair with some of
the counsellors
they've not looked at the the actual
white paper and without knowing
what the preamble is to some of these
questions without knowing that the
preamble which is in the white paper and
i
i've read it from cover to cover more
than once it's difficult
just to the questions are posed here 22
as a question
but if you want to look at the preamble
before that question in the white paper
will give members a better understanding
and i would have hope
members have been online certainly those
who are involved in planning
and had a look at it but to start taking
all chunks out of this report i think
well uh supported she comes
yeah come straight out of what
counsellor christie said sure
chair ian roland would like to come back
please well ian
thank you chair um just to highlight i
don't think the intent was to
say here that the system delivers all of
the infrastructure that everybody would
wish to see come forward with the site
i think what it's trying to do is
suggest that the process works well
in coming to the best solution that's
possible when you take account of
viability
i think we would all love to say that
you set aside the consideration of
viability
and that we're able to deliver all of
the infrastructure that's required
alongside a development
and what should come forward alongside
developments and
what we think is is necessary
unfortunately
we all know that that's not the case and
in terms of
answering question 22a what we the point
we're trying to make is that
actually we think that the process that
we've got before us
works reasonably well in terms of being
able to identify and select those
priorities
that a site should deliver alongside
that consideration of viability which we
we cannot take away we're concerned with
22a in terms of this national
infrastructure levy
that certainly we would we would lose
that
ability to have that um that negotiation
there it will be set at a level and we
will either get it or we will not get it
and i think that the binary black and
white of the process of the national
infrastructure levy is a real concern
in that it could have impacts around
site viability
sites just not coming forward or it
could be that we're just
losing out on the more attractive and
profitable sites
and not getting the the maximum out of
them that potentially we should be
in terms of that infrastructure take and
that affordable housing take
so it's it's not suggesting that it's
the optimum solution in terms of that
paragraph
what it's suggesting is that as a
process
it works quite well for torridge or be
it that i accept councillor haim's
points um that it isn't where we would
want to be
in terms of what we can deliver
alongside developments and i think we'd
all agree with that
yeah mr haines does that in any way
satisfy
what well i mean we want provisions
which will ensure viability
um assessments are done and afford
affordable housing is fulfilled and the
white paper
white paper does actually have some
suggestions for that you can accept
those without accepting the whole white
paper but
i don't agree that the system is working
well i think a lot of people would
say that as well okay
so your your proposition's still on the
table and it's been seconded so
um we'll go to the vote on it
thank you chair councillor bounton i'm
against
councillor brenton four
counselor bright against that's the
brown
against councillor bushby against
councillor christie or councillor clark
against councillor cottell hunkin
against councillor craigie
again councillor dart
i'm afraid i'll have to abstain because
i've missed about
i don't know five ten minutes so don't
know what you're voting on though
okay thank you councillor ford for
councillor dub against
chancellor hackett i'm sorry i'll have
to abstain
i'm having broadband issues i keep
freezing out i think it's in common with
a lot of councillors tonight
okay thank you councillor haynes or
councillor harding abstain
councillor hawkins
sorry before thank you chancellor
against councillor hicks
against councillor hudson
councillor hurley against
councillor hutchings
no we've lost him again okay thank you
councillor inch
against councillor james
thank you councillor jones i told you i
have to abstain i've been having issues
with my broadband as well thank you
councillor langford
against councillor laws
or councillor leather
jane councillor locke
councillor mcgoff for
mackenzie
against that's the manly
against councillor newton
against councillor pennington
councillor watson against councillor
wiseman
against
okay so that's eight four twenty two
against and four abstentions chair
okay well that's clearly lost so um we
move on then
there's no more speakers on there
no there's not chair no tom thank you
very much i'm going to move to the vote
and
and we're voting on the recommendation
which is to
daughter draft response to government
consultation on a proposed
planning reforms as set out in appendix
one and authorized officers to submit
the endorsed response
to the government and i would i too
would like to add my
um congratulations to the officers for
the work they've put into this one
so and i would like to think that the
government are eagerly awaiting our our
views
would like to come back in
just just to highlight the uh we need to
add in the
element about the final paragraph in
response to question 12 as stated and
the correction of any spelling
grammatical
or other errors of a minor nature right
okay chair sorry we've got
councillor proposing that and a second
from councillor watson
all right oh yeah you'll pick up on yes
that was already agreed yeah yes i've
already done yes
so we go straight to the vote okay
you've now got councillor christie's put
his hand up
oh is this point of order or what well i
was told that i was gonna
um contact uh the planning officers
tomorrow to discuss my point
can i still discuss it and can it still
be included if you're gonna vote for it
now
right yes is that that's
that'll be acceptable
all right okay so we go to the vote then
thank you chair councillor belton four
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
four councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or councillor clark
councillor cottle hunkin
councillor craigie or counselor dart
councillor ford again
councillor gupp
councillor hackett for
councillor haynes or councillor harding
councillor hawkins or councillor heppell
or councillor hicks for
councillor hudson or councillor hurley
or councillor inch for
councillor james
or councillor jones
or chancellor langford
for counsellor laws
or cancel the leather
or cancer lock
mckenzie
for councillor manly
councillor newton or
councillor pennington or councillor
watson
or councillor wiseman
oh thank you
thirty three four one against kirstie
all right thank you councillors
let's hope that they um come and take
notice of it
so we move on to item uh number seven
a the first one is from cancer bright
uh if this is approved this will go to
the properties um
committee so council broke would you
like to state your case for
your notice of motion or uh give reasons
for it and then
we'll seek a secondary thank you sir uh
my notice of motion
will be slightly amended as the gas fire
which is
mentioned was disconnected last week and
it was
removed and disposed of between myself
and the chair of the museum
so you can take that one off so the
motion will read
uh i propose that this council funds
repair and maintenance works
at great torrington's pannier market and
market house these works would include
repairs to the museum lift repairs to
the leaking roof
paint in the front facade of the pannier
market
repairing the rotting window frames
repairing the gates replacing the
lighting for more energy efficient
lighting
and repairs and upgrades to the
downpipes to increase walk capacity to
reduce flooding
i've received numerous complaints about
the conditional opinion market and
market house and turret and as evident
from the amount of public contributions
we've had about this
um the frontages of both buildings are
on the main square
and in such a prominent uh and as such
are in a prominent position
in the town centre on view to residents
and visitors alike
these buildings fulfill important
functions in the town
housing torrington's museum and a vast
collection of artifacts
continued to its history connected to
its history
hosting a variety of shops and market
stores and offering event space
both spaces are grade two star listed
and the front pediment or ornamental
gates
columns and windows are of historic
significance and we have a duty to
preserve these assets
uh action must be taken soon in order
that these buildings are not allowed to
deteriorate further
and funding needs to be put in place to
repair essential elements including
the roof down by window frames gate and
lift
at the same time as these repairs are
being untaken it would make financial
sense
for the facade of the building to be
repainted
a recent pool with weather has
highlighted that the downpipes
in place are insufficient to cope with
the heavy rainfall
and this has led to water damage a
leaking roof has
already caused damage to the ceiling and
upper story of market house
the wooden window frames are rotted and
need significant attention from a
carpenter in order to make them
operational efficient and attractive the
mechanics of the iron gates are no
longer
functioning fully and they need to be
overhauled
the lift in torrential museum is not
operational and therefore two thirds are
off late of the buildings
is actually inaccessible to all visitors
because in accordance with the equality
exactly the museum
must ensure that everyone including
disabled visitors are able to make full
use of the facilities
furthermore the museum and traders will
benefit from an upgraded lighting system
they are hoping to install more energy
efficient and longer lasting led lights
in both the museum and
market this will go some way to reducing
the environmental impact of running the
building
and will be a step in the right
direction towards
torridge's target of achieving a net
zero carbon emissions by 2030
as stated in our climate emergency
declaration
in recent months despite the impact of
kobe 19 the weekly market has seen a
revival
with an increase in local store holders
the market
now has enough demand to run three days
a week at the static shops
in the pena market provide a range of
good quality
quality goods and services with the
most recent additions including an
interiors shop and a nail salon
the panty market is also an important
community space which
pre-coded was used to host the
ever-popular torrent and big thing
which is a community carol service
featuring performances
from torrington junior school
the market area is home to a visual
record of the cavaliers bonfires for the
years which were painted by a local
artist roger davies
and these are enjoyed by both locals and
visitors
uh as well as offering its permanent
exhibits the museum has run a successful
lecture series
on local history topics and it has the
potential to continue and expand on this
provision
if repairs are carried out i've spoken
to the chair of the museum
the business owners of the penny market
and the mayor of great turington
and as you've heard they're all in
agreement that these repairs are
necessary
and will make a significant difference
to this area of the town
thank you jen thank you very much um do
i have a seconder
yep yes um yes chair
i'd like to endorse everything that
counselor bright have said
there's a desperate need of works done
in the panhandle market
as he said it's an entrance to the town
and to the
commons and so i'd like to second that
proposal thank you
thank you very much in that case i'll
put it to the vote yeah you've got a
couple of hands raised
uh well there's no debate about it where
this goes to the vote it's not it's not
unless they're points of order
what are who who wishes to speak a
councillor bushby councillor locke and
councillor brown
well well councillor brown has already
seconded it
yeah okay and that's what pennington's
now raised his hand
we now know we know that it's been
proposed and seconded this would have to
go off to the properties thing so
it's because it's got financial
implications there is no debate at this
stage
later on there will be but not in the
state point of order just a point of
order yes
okay i understand the fire was removed
yesterday
by the clark and councillor
bright um are they qualified to remove
the gas fire and are we
running a risk to our property um by
taking the gas fire out without an
appropriate qualification
i don't i don't think we can answer that
question tonight
all right all right so next person
to councillor bush being councillor lock
the well all i was going to last year
was
rather than voting on on this now i mean
we need some kind of costing so i have
every sympathy but we need to know what
it's going to cost well
that's exactly why if it's to prove the
notice of motion it will go off to the
property things where the costings and
all that will be done
okay and then and then it will come back
to council if there's any uh
proposal to spend money on it all right
castle lock yeah i suppose my question
will have to wait until then because i
understand that
since last year since we took over from
genesis the penny market
that torrid have already spent 20 000
pounds
but that would be a question for the
property management
it will indeed so we're going to vote
kirsty thank you chair
councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton bort councillor
bright
councillor brown or councillor bushby
or councillor christie
clark paul councillor cottle honking
or councillor craigie or
councillor dart
we've just lost her she's just rejoining
kirsty okay thanks
councillor ford for councillor gov
gore councillor hackett for
councillor haines or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
abstain councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor inch for councillor james
for councillor jones
for councillor langford
boar
councillor laws or
councillor leather or councillor locke
or councillor mcgough
four councillor mackenzie
four councillor manley
paul councillor newton
four councillor pennington or
councillor watson councillor wiseman
or that's 33 4 and one abstention chair
thank you very much just clearly carried
out say that we'll go off to properties
now uh counsellors i'm just gonna
adjourn for one minute
i've had two lots of medication this
afternoon prior to an mri
scan so i just need to uh excuse myself
for one minute
that's cool
foreign
right thank you councillors appreciate
that
you don't know how much
right okay so now we go on to the b uh
7b which is a notice of motion from
cancer total honking so if you would
like to proceed with that
thank you in reaction to the devastating
decision by central government to vote
against protecting food standards
i've put forward the following notice of
motion i propose that torridge district
council expresses its anger and
disappointment on the government's
decision to vote against protecting food
standards in the agriculture bill
this is a devastating blow to farmers
and consumers
impacting upon animal welfare the
environment
and public health we urge the government
to reconsider its stance when the bill
returns from the house of lords in
november
i propose this council writes a letter
to central government
as well as our own mp for torridge and
west dev and jeffrey cox
along with the mps from surrounding
constituencies
who all voted against the amendment to
protect food standards
selane saxby for north devon mel stride
for central devon and scott man for
north cornwall
to ask them to put their heads above the
parapet and do what is right for our
communities
and save british farming i declare a
personal interest in that i come from a
farming family
we've been farmers for generations and i
hope to take on the farm in the future
and would like to think that one of my
children might be interested in doing
the same
but this isn't just about farmers this
is about everyone who eats food and that
is us all
our government promised us that in all
of our trade negotiations we will not
compromise on our high
environmental protection animal welfare
and food standards
the government now has the opportunity
to take this promise
and enshrine it in law through the
agriculture bill
as recommended by the house of lords yet
they are failing to do so
when contacting our representative when
contacting our representatives on the
matter
we are given the equivalent of a pat on
the head and told not to worry
we are urged to believe that they can
still be trusted to keep that
promise but if they had no plans to
break it
surely they would have nothing to fear
from these protections being put into
law
the agriculture bill has been
ping-ponging between the house of lords
and the house of commons
and will go back to the commons on
november the 4th
when mps will be asked for a third time
to stand up for british farmers
by voting for amendments to support our
high standards
at the last vote 16 conservative mps
put their heads above the pet and
rebelled
including mp for tiverton and honniton
neil parish
he's a former dairy farmer and chairman
of the commons environment food and
rural affairs committee
mp for north dorset simon hall and
vet and mp for penrith and the border dr
neil hudson
but we need more mps to put their
communities first and do the same this
time including our own mp for torridge
and west devon jeffrey cox
who has always claimed in the past to
champion the farming community who he
represents
the fear of cheap imported food
undermining our standards of production
has united all key stakeholders from the
entire farming community
from the national farmers union the
country land and business association
to vets chefs environmental bodies
including greener uk
and sustain and to the general public
over a million people signed an nfu
petition on the issue
and polls have consistently shown
support for upholding uk
food and animal welfare standards a
recent yougov survey
found 9 out of 10 people thought british
standards should be protected in future
trade deals
all of them are deeply concerned and yet
the government continues to resist
most recently truly judge on the great
british bake off a mother to mp danny
kruger
has quit the conservative party in
protest at the government's stance over
food standards
and said of the vote everybody who cares
about british high food standards
should back our farmers after all we are
what we eat
the current bill leaves the door open to
our domestic standards being undercut in
new trade deals
it risks letting in cheaper agricultural
prod imports
undercutting the high welfare healthy
food our farmers produce
as well as their competitiveness this is
not just about hormone-treated beef
and chlorine-washed chicken but also
matters such as stocking densities
battery cages antibiotic use pesticides
fungicides and more at present we risk
being sold out
and there's the possibility we could let
in lower quality food
to clinch a trade deal which is why it
must be ruled out and the amendment to
the agriculture bill must be agreed
family farms are the lifeblood of the
southwest
72 of devon's land is farmed with the
constituency of torridge and west devon
having the highest proportion of
employment in agriculture
across all of the uk constituencies
in fact devon's gdp from farming is
double that
of the rest of the country as farmers
here in devon
we have pride in our produce farming is
not a job but a way of life
where pro by practices and livestock
have often been passed down through
generations farming is a vulnerable
industry that faces huge pressures at
the best of times
from issues such as crop failure and
disease and now the added pressures of
brexit coronavirus
and climate change the combined
pressures
and continual drive for cheap food and
fears over unfair competition
from imports post-brexit are sadly
having
an inevitable impact on the mental
health
of an already isolated workforce
the result of the vote on november the
4th will have
ramifications for both farming and the
wider public for decades to come
as well as the direct impact on the
farming community which i have focused
on
we also risk bringing long-term health
problems
and pressures on the nhs as a result of
eating
substandard food i've heard many people
say that we just need to buy quality
and buy british this is all well and
good if you can afford to do this
but many people won't have that luxury
and will be forced to buy whatever is
cheapest to feed their family
we cannot blame the consumer these are
difficult times
and people will buy whatever they can
afford the blame lies
the politicians who are failing us we do
not want to see british food undermined
by imported food
that could be produced to standards that
are illegal here
please vote for the notice of motion let
us send a strong message to central
government
and our local parliamentary
representatives and as a council
show our support to our farming and
wider community
thank you thank you
councillor carl hogan and i have a
secondary
yeah i'd like to second um
and in so doing i would just like to say
a few brief words
i have deep concerns about the
government's rejection of a series of
amendments to the agriculture bill
as it leaves both our local farmers
vulnerable to economically
precarious post brexit trade deals
these amendments had sought to guarantee
into law
that no food could be imported at a
lower standard
be it environmental food safety or
animal welfare
than those required by farmers in great
britain
my concern is elevated when i read the
comment of the government
farms minister victoria apprentice such
conditions
would make it very difficult to secure
any
new trade deal in short
our government would be happy to
negotiate aware our standards
standards referred to by our two public
speakers tonight
including those of farmer sebastian
mason
a local toys farm who spoke eloquently
of his concerns
concerns swept aside by government
councillors
we cannot risk the prospect of a trade
deal that seeks to compromise in any way
our high standards and allows our
farming industry
to be economically undermined and permit
such food stuffs
as hormone implanted beef or chlorinated
chicken for example
notwithstanding information brought
before us today from our mp's office
it is our duty to the public we
represent
to make our views firmly clear to
government
and to embolden our mp to support both
our farming community and the health and
well-being of us all
councillors let us support this motion
thank you
thank you chair thank you tom we've got
people who wish to speak i'd like to
start by saying i'm going to enforce our
present constitution namely
you'll only have one bite at the cherry
all right so if you want to speak
you say what you have to say when you do
get the opportunity
uh but you won't be coming back okay
yeah sure you've got councillor bush
being councillor james
bushby thank you chair i'm very
uncomfortable with this notice of motion
um if you go into the uh lib dem office
or walk past the lib dem office in
bridge in um
in biddyford there's a large poster with
a
picture of cancer couple hunted hunk in
there
with a long um a long text
very much along the lines of of what
she's just outlined now
i'm not sure whether this is her own
personal notice emotion or whether this
is the
the lib dem um notice emotion
now as a as an independent council
independent led council
you know i think it's it's it's a shame
that we've let party politics come in to
come into being here so um you know as i
said i feel very uncomfortable with this
so i surely vote him against thank you
the next one councillor james mr james
uh thank you chair i'm having awful
trouble with my wi-fi so i'll be brief
um i've i'd not been to uh
party politics with it this is
straightforward
um protection of our farming i've said
in the meeting last week i've gone
organic
um because i believe that's the way we
should be going we should be juicing
quality food
and what better way of saying to the
rest of the world
our food is top-notch by endorsing this
and putting it into legislation
i notice in one of the comments that
says about it being
a labor and other left-wing
organizations
i cannot imagine the nfu which i'm a
member of
and i used to be a committee member or
the cla
could be described as left-wing
organizations
and i read in the letter that come via
counselor newton today at the bottom it
says about
negotiations with united states
australia and new zealand
well to be absolutely honest it
terrifies me
that we end up in negotiations with them
i've always thought new zealand was a
wonderful place
i've just had a couple years ago my
my vet went out there on an exchange for
six months
she was sent home after three months
because of the perhaps the milk price
the farmers decided not to treat their
animals
at all purely to pick them up out of the
field when they died
um and and i simply i'm concerned
um for my future generations of what we
end up with
um thank you chair thank you
councillor led this next chair
thank you chair well to an extent
i'm on the same wavelength as councillor
bushby
i feel very uncomfortable this is a very
political
statement here really i i
support our farming industry entourage
as much as anybody else does
but having read the reply from jeffrey
cox's office that council newton
circulated
we've already eu food safety provisions
are already
ready on the statute book of the uk
since we've voted to leave the european
union
and again we currently through the
agreement with the eu do import from
countries in the world
products which you know do not meet our
current production standards
that our farmers have to abide by um
so i can see the arguments on both sides
but i really do think
we're getting very very political with
some of these noises in motion lately
and i i'm uncomfortable i'm not going to
be supporting this chair
thank you councillor pennington's next
chair
mr pennington i thank you chair personal
interest uh
family farm here since 1854 although i
wasn't here at the beginning
um i am a member of the nfu and cla
thank you
that's all i want to say thank you
councillor lock
next year yeah i agree this is
it's got too political at the moment i
mean my husband
dalton is a fourth generation farmer and
i've been married to a farmer for 48
years
and does that of interest my son is a
professor at michigan state
university um and his speciality is
um animal science and he deals with
dairy farms he goes all over the united
states
um with dairy farms and i've been to
several
and i've never seen any male and
functioning
or male treatment of any dairy animal so
i do take objection to what one of the
public speakers said tonight
and to some certain things that
counselor
said um so i'm not happy with this
either
thank you that's all chain no one else
just got their hands raised
whoa i'll go
to the vote then okay
sorry now counselor christine councillor
coral hunt could have raised their hands
councillor hicks chad councillor
right doesn't sound like chemistry but
never mind
who's who's speaking now who's who was
the next one counselor christy
counselor christy gone coach christie
yeah thank you um
i'm surprised it's been described as
political we're talking about one of our
main industries
and if we're not allowed to talk about
it because of so-called politics i'm not
sure where we are
i'd just like to congratulate councillor
newton uh it must be the fastest ever
reply anyone's ever got from jeffrey
i'd like to it takes weeks to get any
reply well done
counselor um i've read i actually sent
everybody after i had council newton's
email i sent everybody a link to the
actual debate because i read the actual
debate on this
and it's absolutely fascinating if you
read it because
a lot of the opposition to the
government's
proposals actually comes from
conservatives
in rural areas who realize that this
could be a real death now to a lot of
farmers
and it was absolutely astonishing to get
count
geoffrey cox's reply it's a real
lawyer's letter isn't it if you read it
carefully it's all about
oh yes we're seeking objectives
and you think well if you're seeking
objectives why don't you pass it into
law
um i'm afraid when i read the letter i i
burst out laffy at one point where he
says
that uh i will not support a treaty that
i believe would substantially undermine
our food safety animal welfare
or environmental standards all that
compromises the fundamental principles
of the nhs
and you think wait a minute uh devon the
psychiatric service has already been
farmed out to virgin
how can you believe anything that's in
this letter when you read that
we are talking politics here and we are
talking about a fundamental industry
and i support council of cotton hunken
fully having read that debate
because it's clear that these are merely
objectives and under the pressure of
trying to secure
a last-minute trade deal then lots of
things
will go thank you
councillor hicks snapchat
thank you mr chairman this is nearly
about a spin back from the brexit
escapade few years ago i had the
privilege of going to brussels and
meeting the nfu officials out there
all lovely young people all totally sold
on the brexit idea on the
european idea and
they lost that vote they've not given in
they keep on they persuaded their nfu
employers i have resigned from the nfu
because of their behavior
and this is a political escapade whether
you like it
or not and i'm not voting in favor
thank you uh councillor cottle
hunkington
uh you're gonna sum up now is that the
last speaker because you know there's
there's councillor ford right
okay well uh a councillor ford and then
cottle hunter because uh cuddle uh
council catalan can
sum up at the end all right
yeah um hear me chair yes i can hear you
yeah yeah well whether this is political
or not perhaps um some of this
from some of the speakers has been even
though they're meant to be independent
it's probably
been discussed at the econ club but
anyway let's spider-bye
this basically just makes standards and
quite frankly if nothing is going to
change then
just you know just put it in the law so
i will be supporting it's as simple as
that
you know i don't really see the argument
right okay uh tom is that the last
speaker because then the
counselor coddle honking can sum up then
yeah that's creature
okay counselor coddle will you sum up
now please
yeah i just wanted to come back on the
comments about this being political
and reiterate that this is something
i've put forward personally
i've had no one come to me asking me to
pull it forward
it's something that i've noticed is
happening i'm deeply concerned about it
and that's why i've put it forward to
this council so that we can try and put
some pressure on our local mps to
hopefully make a difference
and really people support it because it
really does affect
a massive part of um our
constituency and i just really hope it
gains support
thank you thank you okay so we'll go to
the vote now
um are you ready then uh kirsty
yes thank you chair councillor belton
i'm absane
counselor brenton or
councillor bright or councillor brown
laura councillor bushby again
councillor christie councillor clark
abstain councillor cottle honking
or councillor craigie
bohr councillor dart
or councillor harding abstain
councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel abstain
councillor hicks against
councillor hudson paul
councillor hurley abstain
councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james or councillor jones
abstain councillor langford
four cancer laws
sorry counselor laws
thank you chancellor leather
abstain council mackenzie
four councillor manly
for councillor newton
abstain councillor pennington
or councillor watson
or councillor wiseman
against thank you
okay so that's 24 5 against antenna
abstentions chair
right thank you very much councillors so
that's
clearly carried so now uh
we move to
illusion of the public the vote to go to
part two firstly i'd like to thank
members of the public who have joined us
on
youtube thank you very much for
listening in and
we now have to uh go into uh part two
so uh i need to take a vote on that
i'll propose from the chair we're moving
to part two secondary
yeah again yeah thank you councillor
watson
so once again kirsty please
thank you chair councillor belton for
councillor brenton or cancer bright
or councillor brown
councillor bushby
councillor bushby
oh now we must have lost him okay thanks
councillor christie
oh counselor clark
councillor cotter honking oh that's
or councillor harding
for councillor hawkins
or chancellor heppel
or councillor hicks
for councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor hutchins
or chancellor inch or
chancellor james for
councillor jones or
councillor langford for
councillor laws or
counselor leather or counselor lock
or councillor mcgoff yes
council mackenzie for
councillor manly for
councillor newton or council
pennington councillor watson
councillor wiseman